LEE DENNISON: You ready?
IAN BARBER: Hm-mm.
LEE DENNISON: Go.
IAN BARBER: Hello everybody,
and welcome to the second
attempt at the Google+ EMEA
platform office hours.
We had a bit of a technical
difficulties last time.
And this time, we've attempted
to resolve those technical
difficulties.
Hopefully, if we have any more
problems this time, they'll be
entirely new and unexpected.
With me, as always,
is Lee Dennison.
LEE DENNISON: Hi, everybody.
IAN BARBER: And over on
Hangouts, joining us from
Spain is Silvano Luciani.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Hola!
IAN BARBER: [CHUCKLING]
OK, cool.
So, today, what we're going to
talk about a little bit is
DevFest, which is sort of
happening at the moment in
various places around
the world.
Then we're going to look at
something that came out of the
London DevFest, which is a
Hangout application that
Silvano built, so he's going
to take us through that.
And then finally, if you've
got any questions, we'll
handle that.
Otherwise, we'll say goodbye
and catch up
with you next time.
So DevFest is our sort of
first point of call, and
that's something that was kicked
off the weekend before
last, in fact, in London, and
is a global event with
conferences happening all over
the world just to investigate
and celebrate very bits of
Google technology, and web
technology, and mobile
technology, and all the kind
of cool stuff that's
being built.
So they're organized by the
local Google Develop Groups in
different regions, and we have
the advantage of going along
to the London one.
But in between them,
we've had events in
[INAUDIBLE], in India.
We've had events in Shanghai--
all over the place.
It's been really amazing.
And over the next few months,
we've got them coming up
across the world.
I think the next
one's in Kyoto,
which might be tomorrow--
pretty soon.
And if you want any more
information on that, go to
DevFest.info, where you can see
all the upcoming events.
We thought it might be
interesting to show you some
of the pictures from DevFest
London, so you can get a
little bit of a feel for what
it was like and also to talk
about what some of our favorite
sessions were there.
So, Lee, I believe you've got
some photos you can stick up.
LEE DENISON: Yep.
IAN BARBER: So, if we--
--simplifying your life, making
things a bit easier
while making web apps
of all kinds.
So it comes with a whole bunch
of tools already out of the
box, configurable for you.
It's a package manager, and it's
a build tool that can get
your application ready to go
up-- very, very fantastic, and
a useful set of functionality,
and a really interesting talk
from [INAUDIBLE], not just about
Yeoman, but also about
how you integrate a tool chain
into your process, looking at
how he uses sublime text in
his editor to improve what
he's doing to make it a little
bit more powerful to allow him
to get more done in the same
amount of time-- very, very
interesting talk and
definitely worth
checking out Yeoman.io.
There's some good intro
videos on the site.
LEE DENISON: --talk, he was
getting tips and tricks to
developers who were looking to
get the most out of Jelly
Bean, and to take advantage of
the new features that have
been released in Jelly Bean,
and help their applications
really fit in with the look,
and feel, and the UI that's
coming in Jelly Bean.
So, yeah, that was a
great, great talk.
IAN BARBER: Excellent.
Cool.
So one of the things that we
actually presented as part of
DevFest was a Hangout
application that Silvano and I
talked about on stage there.
But if you're interested about
any of the other things that
are happening at the DevFests,
or you'd like to check out
some more events in London, do
check out gdg-london.com,
which is the site of
the London GDG
Google Developer Group.
Unfortunately, the next meeting,
which is next week,
is all sold out.
It's about cloud technologies.
But stay tuned.
There'll be further things
coming up, so
it's worth a look.
But I think now, one of the best
things to do would be to
just switch over to Silvano.
And, Silvano, perhaps you could
take us through the
application which you built.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yeah.
Sure, Ian.
So just let me quickly
introduce the
story of the app.
The app is called "Being Paul
Irish." Paul Irish is a
developer advocate for Chrome
based in the United States,
and in July, he came to London--
visiting with members
based in London with
other team members
coming from the US.
And they did one of these Google
Developers Live events
for the Chrome platform.
And when they came back to that
area where we sit all
together in the office,
[INAUDIBLE]
was saying, oh, it could be
really cool if we could have
Paul Irish up here in
all of our Hangouts.
And I was there listening, and
I said, yeah, we can do that.
So we took a couple of pictures
of Paul, and then I
wrote this, and now I
will show it to you.
MALE SPEAKER: Hey there.
I'm Paul Irish.
SILVANO LUCIANI: --in the
Hangout, so you can see this
nice overlay of Paul's face,
and the animation of the
mouth, which is more or less
going on when I'm speaking.
The app is actually
a very simple app.
And I'd like to show the source
code to you if we can
go with the slides.
This is from the slide
pack that Ian and
I used at the GDG--
at the DevFest London--
and this is the way you can
launch the app, so you're
seeing a Hangout [INAUDIBLE].
It's very, very simple code.
It's mostly boilerplate.
And the only thing that you need
to personalize is the ID
of your app that you can get
from the Google API console.
If we can go to the
next slide--
so this is an example of
a standard Hangout App.
And when I say standard, I mean
that this is XML code.
But we have published the
service, which is called the
Hangout iframer.
That will allow you to write
your app using your HTML, and
then the Hangout iframer will
take care of grafting your
code into an XML in an iframe
inside the Hangout.
And you can find more about this
at hangout [INAUDIBLE]
.blogspot.com.
And I personally recommend to
use it because I like HTML way
better than the XML code
in my [INAUDIBLE].
If we go to the next, we can see
this is the beginning in
the head of the code.
One thing that I'm doing and
that I wanted to show with
this app is initializing
Google Analytics.
It's very important when you
write a Hangout app to be able
to measure the engagement
that the app is
generating with your user.
And Google Analytics is the
most straightforward
way of doing it.
And you don't need anything
special when it comes to
Hangout Apps.
It's just another web property,
as any website, so
this is the plain, standard,
boilerplate code that you can
get when you create a property
on Google Analytics.
And the only thing that you
will need to change, of
course, is the code
for your property.
And we will see later how to be
able to push events, to be
able to track, for instance,
when users are performing some
actions on your Hangout App.
The most important part is at
the end of the code, and we
include the [INAUDIBLE] for the
Hangout API and then the
Hangout API itself.
Next slide please.
So this is all my initilization
code.
It's a bunch of variables that
I use to store the frames for
the animation.
It's very simple.
We have six frames.
It's basically Paul's face,
and then Paul's face with
different degrees of openness,
let's say of his mouth.
Then we have a couple of
messages that we use for the
button that enables
and activates the
overlay on the face.
And then the most important
part is at the end.
Before we start doing anything
inside a Hangout App, we need
first to be sure that we
have loaded the API.
And for this, we used
the [INAUDIBLE]
API ready event, and we add
the listnet, which in this
case is the function initApp.
If we can move to the
next slide, please.
This is initApp.
And once again, all I'm doing
is just organizing my logic
for reverting some of the
things like getting the
participant ID for the local
participant, which we will use
later to get the changes in
the volume for the local
participant.
And then the unit functions for
the overlays, the sounds,
and the events that we add
to the user interface.
Next slide--
now, unit overlays is the most
important function in this
application where the main part
is played by the overlay
of Paul Irish's face over the
local participant's face.
As you might know if you've used
already the API, first,
you need to create an image of
sorts from a PNG file on http,
preferably.
And then once we have the image
results on top of the
image results, we can create the
overlay, specifying where
we want the overlay to be put.
In this case, it's the nose
[INAUDIBLE], because it's more
or less in the center of the
face so that our face overlay
will be centered all
over the face.
One thing that I wanted to show
is one edition from the
latest version of the API--
v1.2.
And this effect that we can
now manage the resources.
So we can decide to perform
some action just when the
state of the image
results change.
And we can use this also for
sounds and overlays.
So in this case, what we do is
we check, and when an image is
actually loaded, we call the
image loaded function.
As we will see later, what this
does is making sure that
the button that enables to show
the overlay is activated
only when we have already loaded
all the images that are
the frames for our animation.
In this case, I'm not doing
anything particularly useful
in the case that the image
is not loaded.
I'm just writing a message
to the console.
But, of course, you could try,
for instance, to reload the
image resource if there's been
some problem, or send more
meaningful messages
to the user.
In initsounds, it shows
another edition
of v1.2 of the API.
And in this case, initsounds
when I show the
face of Paul Irish.
That's also a salute from Paul
that I read of one of his
very, very interesting video.
It is the one on [INAUDIBLE]
from the [INAUDIBLE], that I
strongly recommend to watch.
And the addition from the v1.2
is the possibility of great
sounds which are global, meaning
that they are not
played only on the local
instance of the app, but they
are, let's say, broadcasted, so
every instance of the app
will play the sound.
And in this case, as you see,
we used the [INAUDIBLE]
parameter set [INAUDIBLE], and
this means that the sound will
be global, and everyone will
be saluted by Paul in the
moment where we apply
the overlay.
Next slide, please.
So this is the function
that actually
activates the overlay.
It's very simple.
So we add or remove a listener
to the volume change event.
With the Hangouts API, we can
get updates on the volume of
each participant.
In this case, the volume is the
input from the microphone.
So what we do is if the
overlay's active, we have the
[INAUDIBLE] that will animate
the mouth when the volume
changes, and otherwise, we
remove the [INAUDIBLE]
so that there's no animation.
One important thing
is at the end.
There you can see how it is to
track events with Analytics.
It's just calling the push
function with track event
parameter, and then you can
define your own event.
In this case, our label
is [INAUDIBLE]--
is the way I call this event.
And I'm tracking with
event [INAUDIBLE]
if people feel like Paul, or if
they don't feel like Paul,
meaning that I will see how many
times they click to show
or write the overlay.
And as you can see, it's very
simple, and you can use it for
all kinds of interactions and
actions that the user can
perform on your app.
And this is the function that
animates the mouth.
Once again, it's quite easy.
So what we do, we check the
volumes of our local
participant.
To do so, we need the
participant ID because on this
event, the parameter for this
event is an array [INAUDIBLE]
by participant ID.
What we do, if the volume
is more than zero,
we animate the mouth.
Otherwise, we just show the
frame with the mouth closed,
meaning that we are
not speaking.
And that's all.
IAN BARBER: Cool.
All right, Silvano.
Thanks.
So that just goes to show you,
really, how simple it is to
put together a app
using Hangouts.
It's really something that you
can do very, very easily--
very, very quickly.
And it's not something that
really requires a great deal
of investment of time
to get going.
That's one of the nice things--
you can do it,
basically, as a joke, which is
what the results of the Paul
Irish app is.
The other thing that's really
important to remember with
Hangouts is that kind of app,
with doing something like a
facial overlay or something on
the screen works, but it's not
the only kind of app
you can build.
You also have the flexibility to
put a A-frame into the main
section of the Hangout
app and build
whatever you want to there.
So that last slide, you just
saw a little bit of at the
end, that was from a game called
WarLight, which is a
really fun kind of risk style
game that you can play via
Hangouts with your friends.
And you can build anything
like that into your
application.
So you can go and take an
application which exists
somewhere else and add video
chat to it with a Hangout, or
you can go and build some crazy
new experience or new
kind of game that works
within the Hangout.
So it's very, very flexible
and definitely something
that's worth looking into.
If you're interested in doing
more with Hangouts, or you'd
like to try something out, if
you go to developers.googl
e.com/+/hangouts--
that's the plus sign--
then you'll find sample apps,
you'll find API documentation,
you'll find lots and lots of
stuff to help you get started.
And we'll put a link to that
in the [INAUDIBLE]
about the show.
So that was the kind of Google+
presentation at
DevFest London.
I hope it was interesting
for everyone.
And the rest of the day on
Friday actually was filled up
with a couple more
presentations, and then we
went down and did some
enlightening talks with people
like Ilmari Heikkinen, gave a
really, really great talk
about doing images--
multiple resolution images--
and a few other people talking
about some things that made a
difference to them or
that they wanted
to share with people.
And then on a Saturday, we
actually had a hackathon.
So the hackathon was a really
interesting day full of
coding, building projects based
on all these different
technologies, and people came
up with games, with
applications for doing video
streaming, via get user media
in the browser--
with all sorts of different
things, which made it just a
really, really great day to be
around, so I would definitely
say if there is a DevFest near
you, get along to it.
Check it out, and see if there's
anywhere you want to
speak or anywhere you just
want to go along to.
So I think that's probably about
it from me, unless we've
got any questions.
LEE DENNISON: I just had a quick
look, and I've not seen
any questions on the
[INAUDIBLE], so I
think that's it.
IAN BARBER: Excellent.
Well, apologies again to
everyone that turned up last
week and suffered through our
technical difficulties, but
hopefully, we've gotten
it sorted out.
It looks like this
week has gone OK.
Particular apologies to the
amazing Gavin [INAUDIBLE], who
we brought along last week
and then completely
failed to get on air.
So, Gavin, we will get back
with you in the future.
We'd love to have you on now
that we have some idea of what
we're doing.
So, thank you, and that's
it from me.
LEE DENNISON: And that's
IAN BARBER: All right.
See you later guys.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Bye.